foreign
foreign
and welcome to the very first Ubisoft
forward for Skull and Bones I'm Yusuf
your captain for today
our main show will start shortly and
will reveal brand new gameplay of skull
and bones in the meantime we wanted to
get you in the mood to set sail
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay that was one of the coolest things
I've ever seen I feel like I can smell
it can you smell it I can smell it
smells like freedom for real it's always
incredible to watch an expert at work we
hope you enjoyed this first part the
official gameplay reveal will start in
just a few minutes but before that let's
check in with some of the development
teams in Singapore and introduce you to
the world of skull and bones
I mean it's really about the the
challenge we're creating something new
yeah I totally agree
like we can't get into details but it
really is like we're creating a player
multiplayer game with a huge world that
doesn't look like sorry guys
[Music]
working on the first new IP uh or
Ubisoft Singapore is so exciting because
it's the first you know where we have to
explore we have to try a lot of new
things out
um we've gone through many iterations
but right now I reckon we have the best
product and I'm very proud to to
represent Singapore southeast Asia and
and release a triple A game yeah for me
working on uh Ubisoft Singapore's first
triple a project has been an absolute
honor and a privilege uh it doesn't come
without its challenges though um
building a complex game with multiplayer
and big worlds and and of course
reaching the level of quality visually
we demand has been quite a challenge but
I'm super proud to see the game changing
involve and happy with where we are
today and I can't wait for people to see
it it almost feels like we're getting an
opportunity to create history
um not just by building this game that's
being driven from Singapore but also the
fact that it's telling the story of
um marginalized people from the 17th
century and getting to work with such a
vast group of people and so so many
disparate talents
um to make it happen it's just been an
incredible experience I'm really proud
to have contributed to that what Mimi's
proud of course working with people that
you know everyone is so talented and
seeing the result being built up at this
point of time is very
emotional and I very enjoying to see the
result I'm not gonna lie it's been
really challenging but at the same time
you know it's it's really brought this
huge opportunity to bring something
completely new and Innovative to to the
industry like how we're bringing this
fresh flavor of piracy and and for us to
be doing it right um from Singapore and
you know I think I think there's
something really exciting there what
would your pirate name be I was thinking
of something really metal something like
Thor the
revengeance
that's something like that if I was a
pirate I'll be completely honest and I
would not make a very good pirate I
would be exploring I might be known as
something like Captain gray eyes the
long-haired doofus and I would be sunk
immediately and rough but I would be
exploring all the beaches and enjoying
all the food with the local people from
my pirate name I'd be Eric the brown
just like Eric the Red but darker
pirate Queen ashbringer because you know
fire Brimstone cannons
strategy combat death so yeah Ash bring
up watch out for me skull and bones is
here
[Music]
foreign
Ty has rules
it decides where you belong
and what you're with
but you
you can chart a new course
[Music]
even when death seems a certainty
do not give up
on the shores of a new world
you awaken
more determined than ever
to carve a life of your choice
fighting under our own flag we will take
what's ours
together
we will take on the world
Society may have rules
but today
you decide where you belong and what
you're worth
I'll choose
will you live as pawns or die as pirates
there was a pawn or die as a pirate you
best believe it's the pirate's life for
me my name is Yusuf and welcome to the
worldwide gameplay reveal of skull and
bones and oh yes we do have a launch
date the game is coming November 8th
2022 and joining me today on the deck of
this gorgeous ship is world producer
Vanessa ciao hey Vanessa hey yourself hi
everyone and game director Ryan Bernard
hey Ryan how's it going Yusuf hello
everyone
Now Vanessa we just got our first look
at the new skull and bones and it looks
like things have changed quite a bit
well can you tell us about this new
Direction yes our team has been working
really hard and we are so proud to
present what you see in the game today
forget everything you know about the
traditional pirate fantasy skull and
bones is taking a darker grittier
approach with our new game direction we
wanted to reimagine what Pirates were
really like drawing inspiration from the
Indian Ocean during the Golden Age of
piracy so you start as a survivor of a
shipwreck right washed up on an unknown
mysterious exotic location this is a
world where everything and everyone
wants you did and for ordinary people
like you and me the only way to survive
is to become a pirate and once you've
chosen that life of piracy there's no
turning back oh there's no turning back
for me I've already chosen the life of
piracy what does that entail exactly
well the world of skull and bones is
ruthless you'll come face to face with
its many dangers from vicious hippos and
crocodiles to Violent storms pirate
Hunters powerful corporations and even
the Mutiny of your very own crew so
every time you set sail it's going to be
an unpredictable experience
me okay okay I'm making a note right now
keep the crew happy
but Ryan obviously a pirate is nothing
without their ship how do we go about
building our Fleet true well skull and
bones is an open world or more aptly
open sea pirate experience right so you
start the game you basically have
nothing you have our smallest ship which
we call the Dow a basic spear in order
to defend off this Wildlife that's
coming after you and really as you
progress you'll need to collect the
things you find in the world and gather
them as you do contracts for the Pirates
you come across doing that will grow
your infamy which will give you access
to new blueprints or designs and allow
you to craft new ships different weapons
different armors and that's how you
build your Fleet in the game Yusef So
eventually you'll be able to rule the
Seas okay I like that building my fleet
ruling the Seas sign me up for that I
want that I want the Thundering cannons
sinking ships the whole nine yards but
you know between us give me The Insider
tips here how do I make sure I'm the
most feared pirate on the ocean oh well
I mean the short answer is just to get
good at the game you said but I mean but
really uh seriously the naval combat is
at the core of Skull and Bones pirate
experience right and we aim to have Best
in Class Naval Combat so we wanted to be
visceral fast-paced rewarding and we do
that part of the way we do that is to
offer the player a wide variety of
different weapon choices which you
unlock through infamy so you've seen
cannons for instance but we also have
Greek Fire we have explosive mortars we
have bombards that you can lob onto the
decks of enemy players and sink their
ships and that'll allow our players the
creativity to combine different weapon
types different armor types and
different ship types to give them the
best chance of success while they're out
at Sea pirating so the Greek fire that
you just mentioned is actually pretty
cool so with leather armor you know get
it out on your brick well I have to
admit that I do get satisfaction
watching other ships burn oh wait that
sounds so cool I want to light other
ships on fire I don't how do I do that
okay so uh as our pyromaniac has
explained here the Greek Fire is one of
the weapons you have also the ship she
mentioned and the armor are things that
you will unlock through gaining infamy
in our progression system so of course
classically Pirates were all about their
name right you were nobody without your
name and our progression system is is
the same we call it infamy so as you
have success in the game and you
progress and your name is going to be
known throughout the Indian Ocean and
pirates from further and further away
are going to want to offer you more and
more dangerous jobs with bigger and
bigger payout which will give you access
to better rewards in the game so the
name of the game is raise your infamy
and you'll have better opportunities oh
okay so I'm imagining the road to infamy
is going to be tough and lonely but it
doesn't have to be right true so first
off I mean everything in scolic modes
can be played solo but at our core we
are a social game right with the the dev
team we look at everything through the
lens of Co-op we want to ensure that
things like taking on the big pirate
hunters or privateers or taking on a
fort in the game is more rewarding and
actually easier when you play with other
players right so we can say that really
the best way to play Skull and Bones is
With Friends
now here's the important question sure
can I team up with my friends and Hunt
other players yeah we can team up
against Ryan okay so this happens far
too much in our internal tests okay so
you can as a player choose to opt into a
PVP server in which case you will be
able to shoot another players sometimes
in our weekly test that happens far too
often to certain people uh with the team
trying to take them out with this vast
array of weapons but so I can say for
certainty that the best way to play is
to have players with you to to watch
your back you know I can't wait to get
in these PVP servers because I want to
hunt specifically you Ryan okay putting
a Target on your back right now I'm
expecting all applications to come help
me uh but Vanessa Ryan thank you so much
for joining us thank you and for
everyone watching at home you've heard
us talk about Skull and Bones it's now
time to show you Skull and Bones here's
the world premiere of our Gameplay
trailer
welcome to Skull and Bones our game
takes place during the Golden Age of
piracy and a world inspired by the
beautiful yet dangerous Indian Ocean
you'll start your journey as an outcast
whose goal is to become the most
infamous pirate to sail these
treacherous Waters
after surviving a shipwreck you begin
your adventure in Saint Anne one of the
pirate dens in our world dens are
centers of pirate activity where you can
craft new ships and Equipment provision
for your Expeditions at Sea pick up
contracts and socialize with other
players
any pirate with their cell will tell you
that preparation is key to success
get ready for any challenges that come
your way by checking that your cargo is
stocked with items like food and
ammunition once you're set it's time to
head out and explore
as a rookie pirate you'll only have
access to a small Dow but as you
progress you'll be able to craft
different ships each with their own
unique play style
at Sea you'll need to pay close
attention to the condition of your ship
and the morale of your crew your crew
are a pack of vicious Raiders and Rovers
who will Mutiny against you if not kept
well fed and happy
if your ship sinks you'll lose some
progress and respawn at the nearest
discovered Den or Outpost
the good news is that most of your cargo
will be recovered and you'll have the
opportunity to retrieve the rest from
the wreckage but you'd better be quick
as other players can also steal it
foreign
as a pirate Captain your reputation is
everything and our game tracks this
through infamy the higher your infamy
the more opportunities you'll get one of
the many ways to grow your infamy is to
take up contracts these are deals that
you can make with other pirates in the
world contracts can have great rewards
if you're successful or costs if you
fail
you can also gain infamy by completing
other activities such as exploration
plundering treasure hunts investigations
Dynamic events and much more you can
undertake these either Solo or with
other players the world of skull and
bones is filled with riches and
resources that you'll be able to gather
as you explore
lagoons and rivers are teeming with
dangerous wildlife that you can hunt for
animal skins and meat
you'll also be able to harvest a variety
of raw materials such as ore and wood
that can be refined and used for
crafting
crafting is an essential activity for
you to progress as an Infamous pirate
obtain Blueprints and use your refined
resources to craft stronger ships
weapons and armors
in Skull and Bones ships serve many
different purposes cargo ships are
slower but useful if you need to
transport large volumes of loot
navigation ships sail faster but have
less cargo space and lower Hull HP
Firepower ships have more gun ports
allowing you to deal higher damage but
are more challenging to maneuver
similarly you can craft a wide array of
unique weapons and armors from Greek
fires to Giant ballisti to rocket
launchers and mortars as well as
different armor types which have varying
strengths and weaknesses against
incoming attacks
with your new Fleet and growing Arsenal
create a Loadout based on your personal
play style to become a force of
Destruction
out in the open ocean opportunities and
threats are abundant use your Spyglass
to identify lucrative trade routes or
wealthy Merchant ships and assess your
praised cargo and Firepower
strategize a plan of attack based on
your opponent's defenses and take
advantage of their weak points to deal
more damage
sinking your foes from afar rewards you
with only a portion of their cargo as
some of it will be lost to the depths
getting in close to execute a boarding
maneuver will help maximize your gains
but beware you can turn from Predator to
prey in a heartbeat if you attract The
Unwanted attention of privateers the
merciless pirate Hunters that Patrol the
Seas
if you enjoy the thrill of the hunt you
can also seek out other players and
Reign Terror on them
such PVP battles are high-stakes
activities that can be rewarding if you
emerge Victorious
from your Spoils of battle personalize
your individual look with outfits that
command respect
[Music]
you can also select from a multitude of
ship customization options to instill
fear in your enemies
foreign
With The Wind in your sails Journey to
the furthest reaches of the Indian Ocean
from the coast of Africa to the East
Indies
encounter extreme weather events like
violent storms and monstrous Road waves
keep your eyes peeled for outposts which
are safe spots where you'll be able to
dock your ship for a short rest from the
perilous Seas here you can trade with
traveling merchants and clandestine
Smugglers selling rare and illegal Goods
uncover buried bounties at outposts as
you decipher treasure maps obtained
through your voyages although all the
content and skull and bones can be done
solo you might enjoy ruling the Seas
with your friends while sailing you can
also easily invite other Pirates you
encounter to group up synergize your
different play Styles ships and weapons
to defeat deadlier enemies
as you grow stronger take on more
difficult challenges such as attacking
Forts and plundering settlements and if
you're bold enough engage in Dynamic
events like taking down heavily Laden
Merchant ships and their Fleet of
Warship escorts
now it's up to you to write your own
story remember there is no one path to
follow no one way to play the world of
skull and bones is yours to discover
okay that was a lot did you get it all
let's recap we got pirate thens crafting
customization Naval Combat tons of ships
and weapons infamy Co-op PVP world
events and so much more and that's not
it y'all here to give us a sneak peek of
what to expect from Skull and Bones post
launch is our game's Quest director
Terry Han it's Eric hello Yousef hello
everybody now Terry what can we expect
from Skull and Bones post launch well as
a live multiplayer game our team is
dedicated to deliver the best open world
pirate experience for our players with
the sky and Bones team we are committed
to provide fresh new content not just in
the coming months but for many years to
come
after release we'll have a lineup of new
content and these are all free for our
players these include in-game War events
ranging from bigger daily challenges
that you can take as a group two smaller
team events ships weapons furniture and
many more free content for all players I
love to hear that Terry tell me a little
bit more about these challenges so you
can expect to not just engage with the
local factions but also with big
corporations like the company Royale who
has really strong bombard weapons so you
really need to watch out for that aside
from that you also work with kingpins to
smuggle and steal valuable Cargoes or
even go on a raid with your friends to a
nearby settlement or Fort or even engage
with a dynamic events where you can
board Merchant ships stealing valuable
Cargoes along the trade routes okay it
sounds like there's a ton of content
coming post launch I can't wait to get
my hands on it Terry thank you so much
for joining us thank you Yousef and to
everyone watching don't go anywhere
there's still a ton of content coming in
our post show but before then we're
going to check in with our community
developer Alexi [ __ ] who's going to
introduce us to the official Community
live stream the deck
thank you Yousef and thank you so much
to all of you for being here with us
today
over the past few months we've been
working very closely with our community
to refine our game and as we get up to
launch we'll be doing more of this
we will have Hands-On opportunities in
the coming months so register your
interest at our website skull and
bonesgame.com speaking of which The
Insider program is also in full swing if
you like what you saw today and want to
help us go and sign up all you have to
do if you select it is play the game
regularly and if you want share your
feedback with us
last but not least today we're also
kicking off the deck our official
committee live stream we want to bring
the people behind the game direct to you
think streamers YouTubers role players
Community leaders meet and chat with our
developers our artists or producers
basically all the people who work their
magic on this game and can't wait to
hear from you that's happening right now
with Ryan as a first guest so stay tuned
and enjoy
foreign
hello again and welcome to the tech
today we are officially kicking off the
first of our community live streams with
a special episode during weeks from
showcase more of screen bones gameplay
Ryan and I will take you through a high
level contract and show you how the game
Mechanics Work once you've explored and
progressed through the game
we'll show you some of the ship
customization but also and more
importantly some good old plundering
one more thing before I let you all
Discover it keep in mind that the team
here is still working very hard on the
game so everything you see is very much
a work in progress and still subject to
change
now kick back enjoy yourselves and don't
forget to let us know what you think hey
Ryan how are you doing I'm doing well
Alexi how are you very good thank you so
what are we doing here what's happening
we are in telek panjara which is the
second pirate and that our players will
come across in Skull and Bones
coming we are playing we are actually
playing Skull and Bones so
um we are going to take a contract one
of our quests if you will to go uh
basically help out the local faction
here the rampa against the the evil DMC
and we're going to uh plunder one of
their settlements
so I'm just rolling through the den here
full of different Pirates some other
players
I'm just gonna follow you for a bit okay
and
I'm gonna go to the carpenter here and
you can see by his name that he's got a
contract available for me so I'm gonna
check it out
captain
so get down we can and this one's called
Stevens oil Opus and we're gonna take
that one
and that's going to send this to plunder
what I can do is oh we actually need to
group first so let's
let me
um
find you I'm right in front of you I
think I can just or you can do that I
was gonna do it through the uh here we
go
too I'm faster than you
yes I got it okay we are now we are now
it's gonna show you did you accept all
right did I press the there we go oh
nice playing is more fun with friends
playing is it does it gives you a nice
little message you know it's more fun
with friends so I'm gonna share the the
contract so from our map here I could
see all my different contracts I only
have one right now but I'm gonna go
ahead and share that with you
all right
cool so now I can uh I can see it on my
journal yes
and I see the destination marker on the
map
and I'm gonna go ahead and I'll mark it
for you so we're gonna we're gonna head
out across the bay
to uh a lumber yard settlement from for
the Dutch
so if you go now to the
end of the dock you can
pimp your ride you can set up your
ship with a lot of different
customization options
so I'll take the I think I'm set up for
the Brigantine which is uh one of our
medium navigation ships it's good for
support it's really fast and responsive
but I'll take that I think you're set up
with the Firepower the big boy right so
I've got the brig I think it's pretty
heavy yeah so
um I would check though check your cargo
to make sure you've got some ammunition
some food to feed your your crew and
yourself and uh oh I've got some attack
me too you know what that is it's very
good food I think it's a seafood dish
here in uh in Singapore in Malay yes uh
I have not I'm not big on Seafood uh I
haven't partaked partaken
personally but I hear it's really good
and it's very good in the game for uh
uh keeping your crew happy
so I'm going to just take a look at what
they've set me up with it looks like
I've got the flamethrower the Greek fire
on the front
I've got
um
some bombards some crushing bombards
nice
that'll work on both sides
should I have a red cells of white cells
what's easier for you to recognize me uh
red sails white sales you look like a
merchant and I might try to shoot you
all right let's go for it all right I'm
gonna switch to
uh
let's see
explosive extended Rockets
three
I'll go ahead and sit still while you
get ready okay wait for you around did
you look at your armor I did you did I
have uh I have wooden Armor All Over so
I've got cargo to give me enough space
whoops I've got
uh
uh I've got leather which is good
against fire on the side that's fine
I got Cargo in the back
and I got terracotta I'm going to switch
this up
the metal on this side
so again you know depending on what you
know weapons they're coming at us with
the different uh armors we'll have
pluses and minus uh again that against
that
Furniture what do I got equipped
nice okay I got a repair kit bonus
I've got chip health
uh
nice sales
okay so we have a we have a few of our
friends from our QA team who are playing
the game right now of course some of
them are right here on the one of the
most I think it's actually the smallest
ship in the game the door right the Dow
yes that's our kind of hunter-gatherer
ship yeah so he's busy like fishing
shots basically hunting Wildlife nice
all right I'm heading out
I'm not stalling anymore
I can see where you are on the map you
are yeah I'm just waiting for you yeah
you're just uh I'm going out the other
side but I'll steer towards you oh I
think I see our little uh our little
Hunter here as well Captain wibbles
taking out some sharks
of course you you definitely don't want
to use the big ships on the Sharks
because you'll just blow them up and
there won't be any usable skins or uh
or meat which is definitely what you
want to do when you're hunting those
all right I see you now all right I'm
gonna head across let's see do we Market
I think I mucked it already yeah it's
mucked already
all right I'm heading across as well
so we're going there to essentially just
get what like some jars of oil well
that's the contract the the Carpenters
there's our Mark the carpenter is really
looking for this uh jar jar of oil right
um but this will show off the plunder
mechanics so a lot of the settlements or
uh forts that you'll be able to attack
and engage in the game
um use whoa that was cool yeah what shot
there's a lot of fun use uh what we call
plundering so essentially your crew goes
ashore into the settlement they're
ravaging uh the goods and commodities
and they're filling up a barge which you
can then loot at any time and you can
leave and your job is to stay alive and
take out any maybe reinforcements that
come along or take out the towers along
that are set up to defend the settlement
um as you can see the Dutch here
already with a couple towers and a
couple ships so on the way back we
probably need to be careful because I
think these are some of the other plays
doing some PVP over there what's that oh
there PVP yeah I think you pass right by
then right yeah I did I was focused on
talking about the uh the plunder yeah I
was just because you're getting really
close to them I'll wait till you're in
the area because you're you're lag
behind a little bit it
and you're you're my muscles so I need
you up here up close so probably what's
going to happen
because we're gonna we're gonna see
these all these nice little ships that
are calmly parked here are going to uh
all right I'm here are going to wake up
when I so I I can Spyglass the um
uh the lumber yard here and I can see
and that'll give me the option or when I
get a little closer it'll give me the
option to start uh plunder
here we go
all right I'm gonna start it all right
it's happening now I'm not yeah did you
get the did it start for you okay yeah
I'm gonna see that plunder track across
the top
uh which is Gonna Fill up as we're kind
of as our crew is stealing the booty and
now we're gonna see uh
potentially some reinforces coming
reinforcements come in I'm gonna take
out these towers first off yeah I'm
aiming on the left Tower okay
oh and I get the green arrow up and that
tells me that I'm doing good damage
against the stone here with my explosive
mortars boom oh oh boy I'm gonna brace
see if I can burn this one nice side
incoming
incoming mortars my way but I'm bracing
the damage
we're okay we're okay which one are you
attacking the imagination from me oh
you're checking out the ships okay I'll
try to take out this other Tower I think
I have bombards on this side as well
yeah yeah so the printer is actually a
short work of this guy
[Music]
nice oh yeah
all right tower two is down
all right we got a lot we got a lot of
enforcements coming in well
we'll turn around all right I'm gonna
help you with that guy yeah you almost
got him
see it I see you I see you
can you board him do you want me to sink
him or yeah
all right well he's done yeah I got him
all right we're almost to our first loot
[Music]
but we got a we got another player in
here maybe he's trying to help us
swabby
nice
very at all
all right we got our first
track point
are you still going at it over there
you should repair
okay I'm in the middle of the board oh
you're fighting as well oh my God yeah
boarding is quite dangerous if you do it
at the wrong time right
yes
that was actually you good thing I can't
do damage if you're in the red circles
uh you can reduce the damage
we're definitely getting a lot of
mortars out here
try to burn them a little bit
[Music]
oh I gotta get back in the plunder area
we definitely got to stay in close so
you can't kind of you know sail away
over the plunder will will stop
you guys are hanging around the outside
what are you doing we'll take some get
some orders buddy
sending some as well
look at that burn
but they're trying to drag us out of the
plunder row I don't know I think some
are uh reinforcements coming in and some
are Dutch that are in the area so
they're not all going to come in
that's part of it oh okay spray sprays
I want to finish burning this one
I got I think I got out of the area
you didn't get back any time
oh we hit nice we got two yeah I think
we're doing good we are we're surviving
well we I cheated and took those
bombards against the towers took them
out really really quickly quite like the
combo of Motors to keep it away keep
them away and then the moment they get
close that's why you turn around and use
the flamethrower
yeah it's working very well I was like
this doesn't matter what they fall close
I always have something
just live in these wrecks that you're
sinking I can see that yes
[Applause]
just waiting we got two more tracks and
we finished the hole we get the the
maximum coinage
it looks like you took out all of the uh
reinforcements the last two are just
like nope I'm not going in I've seen the
others I've seen what happened to them
I'm not gonna think so they can't they
can't draw us out all right I'm gonna go
over here and see what's over here
I think maybe some of our uh some other
players are helping us out with some of
the reinforcements oh that's why it
could be
[Music]
true oh oh okay we've got more uh
moon coming yeah yeah
finally
oh yeah that's it
by yourself it's quite it's a lot harder
okay we need to get okay this is serious
business
okay there's like four or five coming in
right there I'm gonna go right in you're
gonna go straight in send them on fire
right away okay I'll try to I'll go long
distance though oh I don't have a I
don't have an auxiliary weapon equipped
okay it's okay
this one's done trying to board him oh
I'm too far away
oh I got it I think I got it yeah
nice
completing challenges which is always
good
all right
oh
[ __ ] me out
I'm on the Rampage
are you just calling all of them I'm
burning them
yeah you think they set you up uh they
set you up a little bit I'm thinking on
like three four ships at the same time
no that's that's that's what happens
when we uh
the dev testers hook you up with a with
a loadout
I mean
[Music]
yeah
you've earned all of this equipment
oh
a bit of boarding I was it was the wrong
weapon type but he's still sorry oh I
think we finished maybe we finished okay
I'm gonna go loot
and
um
foreign
[Applause]
which is what we wanted
are you leaving the area you're taking
the Commodities so I can sell them
A Relic where are you I'm gonna leave
the rest I'm just getting the uh the
loot
all right so let's let's try to head
back across the uh yeah I'm just trying
to clear the Dead Man's straight if you
see anyone is it safe I've got the I've
got the oil I don't want to lose it yes
I mean who's attacking you it's I don't
know where it's coming from but I think
it's this one over there that was really
cool it's long distance
I think it's these guys there oh oh
there's some DMC I think there's some
players in there though too yep you're
thanking us
he's fighting with us right not
attacking me someone's attacking you
yeah I don't know what's coming I think
it's either it's explosive no it looks
really cool it's explosive mortars
they're coming from above
yeah you just just keep them up just
you're a decoy decoy no no
yeah slayer was another player he was
boarding me for sure but I think he got
sunk by the
by the uh the Dutch behind him
no I'm not in cupboard
there you go yes burn him keep him busy
those long range coming in
all right now once I get back to the den
coming into a safe Zone
are you saying somebody nice
I'm waiting so far already because I'm
in the Navigator I'm in the brilliant
team man it's fast you see food nobody's
attacking you anymore no I'm safe I'm
gonna go turn it in
and yeah there's there's a lot the mega
forts down there but let me turn this in
so I'm gonna go so are you still
fighting are you done fighting out there
I'm done fighting now okay
you should get this as well oh no we're
in here in my group okay maybe you're in
combat yeah
we can remove our
um
our hostility
all right we both made it back in life
we did
we made it we got the contract done do
you want to go look for some more
trouble should we go uh I'm just gonna
repair my ship okay you can do that here
and yeah then I'm ready to go again all
right let's go should we go north and
see or did you say you knew uh I want to
go to like the most heated region of
uh I think it's not real yeah I think
it's
I think it's uh but you know what maybe
the the players that were attacking me
just now on my way back maybe they see
his maybe we can take revenge for us
okay you wanna you wanna go after them
okay I think there's something
interesting down there to Market
um
all right let's go look for these
players I mean it wasn't this guy
he's just a little no it wasn't these
guys he's in a little Dao it's just
seeing this guy just Captain wibbles
he's just out here hunting sharks all
day long what do you like to do there
they are
they could have once you once you kind
of uh how do I put this tactfully
retreated
um
we could have headed back let's go let's
go this way go towards my mark
uh
um I think it's deep out down and then
yep
so you get music I don't I do it must be
because I'm the group leader
I'm the group cat I'm the group Captain
yeah they're mad at you
beautiful the weather is really nice
today so we don't have to deal with
storms that's good
kind of unusual and uh
this area like I'm quite a bit faster
than you
you're way faster I feel very heavy yeah
are you in cupboard no no okay
oh you know there's there's a we need to
give a good reason to have the different
ship classes right so navigation ships
are quite a bit faster this is the
fastest ship we have in the game
Brigantine right now oh okay I see some
stuff over here that looks uh
it looks like we could be
moving into uh some Dutch territory some
hostile territory which means that even
if they weren't already mad at us which
they aren't currently because we because
our hostility wore off because we paid
off somebody right too no I didn't
actually I didn't find them in telecon
jar we just headed back out
but it drops eventually right
um doesn't take too long but if you
build it up too high you do have to pay
a fixer to to lower it so are we aiming
for that I got Tower over there this is
the Dutch controlled Waters right so
normally you go in here uh well I guess
like you know well-equipped group of
pirates
but if we get too close to any of the
settlements or the ships they're going
to uh engage us
and I think this is a fort in front of
us
some things to engage over here there's
four Towers
yeah you're coming to turn red your
compass will turn red to let you know
and the towers are like not happy that
I'm here no
so we'll see how long we last here I'm
gonna fight back the day yeah of course
where where are you oh you went too
close to the one on the side okay I've
got the ones in the front here there's
five of them
race
it's a it's a I think uh we've moved
into a higher tier of enemies although
we have backup someone coming I think
other players are following us and
helping us nice nice oh they're
attacking me now I'm not nice not nice I
thought they were with us I'm doing good
damage
but I'm taking a lot of damage are you
coming over to attack these with me okay
look on your maps you can see me I'll be
the green ship
I'm right behind you okay so I'm trying
to take out these and I'm bringing those
two players back I can't tell if they're
with us or against us
well hopefully hopefully they're not
against us because we're taking oh my
gosh
we got some some explosive mortars
coming in Grace
yes just well it's just the outside of a
fort
oh
this one we're just destroying so I can
start actually I'll start the plumbing
around I was trying to weaken them a
little bit before we started it what are
you doing
here we go here we go here we go so you
can see do you see how many loot points
there are in this one that also lets you
know that it's more difficult there we
go there we go
I don't think it's gonna end well let's
see maybe these other players will come
join the plunder
the problem is you gotta you gotta the
challenge is you gotta get close
to do I'm doing good bombard damage you
have bombard to use your bombards
um or mortars
but then you're open to their uh
their volleys praise
it's all about timing right finding the
right time to shoot
and then move yeah
and hope they're aiming at someone else
oh that was cool
oh
oh we got one
yeah it's on the other side there the
loot barge where are we just putting
down already oh yeah they're gonna be
putting reinforcements soon yeah that's
one that's when that's when it's here
yeah YouTube they're right behind you
you keep I got the bombard do you you
take the reinforcements I'll take the
I'll try to take out the keep taking out
the towers
like I think I'm out of grateful damn it
oh you're out of your oil oh maybe I I
no I dumped mine for weight I dumped
mine at the other phone but you should
have picked it up it's okay it's okay
all right you have to use a different
tactic you have to use you have to use
tactic number two now we've only got
I think there's
there's one one Tower left over here
you get rid of these towers it's uh it's
gonna be a lot less dangerous we just
have to survive the reinforcements very
good we can do this we can do this all
right all right more than I have to go
over here we could also just Loot and
leave no I'm I'm like I'm into this
watch out
before they weren't mad before I didn't
know
[Applause]
is it almost down or no we're we're
halfway I think our our friendly Dev
testers definitely helped us out yeah
for sure
it did it did take a look at what's
across the water here very cool
other settlement we could do later
these are really heavy though yeah good
Lord that's what they're going through
I'm just taking two I don't even need
that oh but I'll take two whoops
so close
there it is
plunder complete yes can we get the
infamy big infamy you always end up
looting stuff when I'm still in the
middle of the time how do you do that
well because I know I know where to go I
know where to go come over come come to
the barge it's nothing right well we're
four or five now we run now we run right
now
we need to get out of the uh hostile
territory but I'm gonna go North go I'm
gonna Market go towards that marker
it's getting uh
it's definitely a fog rolled in maybe a
storm is coming
we're not in the open sea though so we
don't worry about roadways or any of
that kind of
one of our friendly QC or QA Dove
testers has decided to come and uh
attack me as I'm trying to get away
killed the player I did yeah well he
came at me uh like a madman he knows he
got loot exactly that area we were in is
actually just a tiny fraction of the
whole thing right yeah the the so the
Romper and the which is a local faction
and the DMC are at war in this whole
area so some areas uh the Dutch Merchant
company controls like uh hostile
territory other areas are kind of open
or the rampant territory so it's kind of
piecemeal through here but of course we
like to help the rhombo and and and and
because we at the underdog and pirate
the DMC exactly which is just what we
did so what are we doing next are we
heading back to I'm heading back to
Telecom to try to stash some of this
stuff in the warehouse before we lose it
oh nice nice beautiful kind of done and
setting here in telegranjara
all our cheeky Dev testers that were
helping us out or and or attacking us
all right we made it we did
that was intense did you like that that
was pretty good yeah it was pretty cool
I really I like the uh the circular
plunders are pretty great they're very
different when you go all the way around
but yeah we got we got lucky that we got
help I think I don't think we would have
survivors to US ah so hopefully that's
uh that was exciting for everyone else
as it was for us
and uh we'll see you out there in the
Open Seas all right thanks a lot Ryan
and uh talk to you soon you too cheers
and with this this is the end of our
show today thank you so much once again
for being here and staying with us all
the way until the end we hope you like
what you saw and we can't wait to read
all of your comments so please go on the
forums go on with it or the social media
of your choice and let us know what you
liked or what you didn't like with your
help we hope to make current Bones the
best pirate game ever
we know some of you are really eager to
play the game and the team here is
working really hard to make this a
reality
we will have live things happening soon
so please keep an eye on our official
channels so you can be the first one to
know when that happens
if you sign up for The Insider program
thank you once again for your
willingness to help us
we can't promise you'll make it but if
you are selected we'll be reaching out
to you by email so make sure you check
your mailbox regularly so you don't miss
out
finally this is only the beginning for
us we intend to continue sharing more
information about screen buns through
future episodes of the deck such as this
one through our official websites and of
course our social media channels
thank you once again for your support
and I'll see you next time bye